ce conseil de défense organise au moment
où je vous parle à Moscou on est à moins
d'une heure maintenant c'est allocution
et de Joe Biden depuis la Maison Blanche
et les
autorités russes Vladimir Poutine le
premier sont en train de tenter de
rassurer évidemment les entrepreneurs
russes au vu des sanctions qui vont être
infligées qui ont commencé à être
infligé à la à la Russie on est avec
vous David Cadier bonjour professeur de
politique européenne à l'université de
Groningen spécialiste de la Russie et de
l'Europe centrale merci d'être avec nous
j'imagine que vous avez entendu les les
différentes réactions communication
aussi parlant peut-être d'abord des des
Russes qui sont en train de s'organiser
et de préparer leur réponse face à ces à
ses sanctions il y a les 27 qui vont se
retrouver ce soir à 20h et qui ont déjà
donné le temps finalement les sanctions
on va frapper fort très fort même les
Russes au porte-monnaie
absolument déjà lundi dernier le
l'ancien Premier ministre medve avait
insisté sur le fait que les Russes
étaient prêts que les Russes
s'attendaient à ce que des sanctions
soient imposées sur l'économie et de
nouveau là il l'aurait affirme et il
faut bien comprendre que les sanctions
en fait marchent lorsqu'elles font plier
les élites qui elle-même se retourne
contre le gouvernement donc je pense que
c'est en train de se passer les images
que vous avez diffusé de ce conseil de
défense c'est vraiment bien Poutine qui
cherche à impliquer toutes les élites
politiques russes les rendre
correspondables de ce qui est en train
de se passer pour en fait essayer de
prévenir toutes défection tout défection
tout autre de soutien au régime
Daru il y a quelques instants qu'il
n'est pas seul à prendre les décisions
le chef du Kremlin qui qui vient de
s'exprimer nous n'avions d'autres choix
nous étions contraint d'agir face face à
l'ennemi
U
ces dernières heures ces derniers jours
un côté russe
absolument c'est vraiment une rengaine
en fait sur parfois des faits qui n'ont
pas qui ne sont pas vérifier dans l'est
de l'Ukraine mais ce qui me semble
vraiment différent cette fois c'est que
depuis ce matin il est clair que les
objectifs de Moscou du Kremlin n'ont pas
très haut Dombas mais on véritablement
très au pouvoir politique à kiaf et donc
toute la guerre internationale qui est
en train d'être préparé au tour de cette
intervention cherche à couvrir l'issue
potentiel des intentions véritables et
selon moi il y a deux scénarios deux
hypothèses possibles soit il s'agit pour
la Russie actuellement de faire plier le
pouvoir politique à Kiev c'est-à-dire de
porter un coup vraiment important à son
moyen de défense à son armée pour la
forcer à négocier à obtenir quelque
chose d'elle et ce matin le Kremlin a
fait savoir que Vladimir Poutine alors
que les les l'action militaires étaient
en cours était prêt à discuter d'une
éventuelle neutralité d'Ukraine ou d'un
éventuel engagement de Kia à ne pas
accueillir sur son territoire les
troupes étrangères par contre le
deuxième scénario qui en a eu beaucoup
plus inquiétant c'est que l'action en
cours cherche plutôt à affaiblir les
défenses de l'Ukraine c'est pour ça que
ce qui disait sont les aéroports
c'est-à-dire l'Armée de l'Air prendre le
contrôle de l'air au-dessus du crâne
pour préparer une invasion terrestre
massive qui déboucherait là par contre
probablement par l'installation d'un
gouvernement fantoche à Kiev qui
répondrait un peu plus directement au
aux ordres de Moscou véritablement les
objectifs à présent pour Vladimir
Poutine sont le contrôle politique de
l'Ukraine et c'est pour ça que c'est
vraiment vers le pouvoir politique à
Kiev qui qui cherche à diriger son
action
actuellement il s'appelle à rassurer
évidemment sa population pour qu'elle
continue à le soutenir et qu'elle reste
derrière lui je le disais une
soixantaine de personnes la dizaines de
personnes antiger qui ont tenté de
manifester leur opposition à ce conflit
à Moscou et Saint-Pétersbourg ont été
immédiatement arrêté la Russie ne veut
pas porter atteinte au système
économique mondial auquel elle
appartient rappelle Vladimir Poutine
s'est effectivement vrai un mot
peut-être de ce que vont pouvoir dire ce
soir les Européens on a entendu les
différentes chancelleries s'exprimer à
l'issue de conseils de défense organisé
dans dans chaque capitale à ce soir on
risque d'assister à un exercice
d'unité c'est l'Europe tout entière qui
qui va s'adresser au monde à la Russie
en premier lieu
absolument ça sera d'abord un message
d'unité des Européens un message de
solidarité envers les ukrainiens et
un message probablement de
l'inacceptabilité de l'action militaire
rue son cours de violation flagrante du
droit international mais probablement
des sanctions également seront annoncées
seront en tout cas discuter les
sanctions prises suite à la
reconnaissance des entités séparatives
du Dombasle était un premier palier les
Européens avec clairement laissé
entendre que si une action militaire
avait lieu des sanctions beaucoup plus
importantes seraient prise il s'agira
maintenant ce soir de savoir quels
seront ces sanctions et qu'elles effets
elles pourront avoir ou non sur l'action
en cours de la Russie merci
d'avoir été à nos côtés pendant cette
édition spéciale